[Musica]
cosa ci spinge a cambiare per ogni
situazione importante della vita la casa
il lavoro il marito la moglie il paese
quello che ci spinge a cambiare è la
convinzione di andare verso un
miglioramento Oppure che sia giusto
farlo o anche la convinzione che non ci
sia assolutamente altra scelta questo è
esattamente l'approccio che di cui noi
abbiamo bisogno quando discutiamo di
cambiamenti climatici da una parte per
accettare i grandi mutamenti anche gli
adattamenti alla nostra vita che
dovremmo accettare noi dobbiamo pensare
di andare verso un mondo migliore delle
città meno inquinate una delle strade
anche più piacevoli un lavoro più
soddisfacente dei nuovi valori di
sobrietà
e anche dobbiamo veramente pensare che
questo vale per tutto il mondo e non
solamente per noi allo stesso tempo
dobbiamo essere informati e anche
consapevoli che se non riduciamo al
massimo le nostre emissioni entro pochi
decenni le conseguenze saranno veramente
tragiche e non ci sarà più nulla da fare
urgenza e desiderio queste Sono
esattamente le chiavi che ci servono per
uscire dall'inerzia nella quale Noi ci
troviamo oggi perché dopo innumerevoli
trattati internazionali molti soldi
anche grandi mobilitazioni leggi siamo
ancora in una situazione nella quale il
nostro pianeta rischia di riscaldarsi di
almeno 3 gradi per la fine del secolo
vorrei approfondire un po' con voi
questa questione dei gradi che non
sempre molto molto chiara nel 2015 è
avvenuto un evento veramente importante
A Parigi c'è stato il primo accordo
climatico globale che è stato firmato da
praticamente tutti soltanto Siria e
nicoragas rifiutarono di firmare in quel
momento e in questo accordo si diceva
che si doveva arrivare ben sotto a un
livello di riscaldamento del pianeta più
basso dei due gradi entro fine secolo e
che bisognava avere come obiettivo
quello di arrivare a un grado Oggi siamo
nel 2022 la temperatura globale è
aumentata di 1,1 gradi Quindi abbiamo
veramente poco ancora da aumentare e per
di più ci troviamo in una situazione che
se nulla cambia rischiamo di aumentare
la temperatura di 2, 6 fino a 2,9 gradi
e per il pianeta come anche per noi il
fatto di avere queste tre gradi in più
cambia moltissimo e addirittura può
essere fatale
molti di noi pensano che questo tema del
cambiamento climatico è un qualcosa che
verrà per i nostri pronipoti e oppure
che interessa qualche atollo lontano
questo non è così anche io devo dire la
verità sono rimasta molto sorpresa di
apprendere Immediatamente dopo la
conclusione della Coop 27 a Sharm el
Sheikh che il continente che in questo
momento si sta riscaldando più
velocemente è l'Europa che ha un che
negli ultimi vent'anni si è riscaldata
un ritmo doppio rispetto al resto del
mondo e devo dire che l'Italia è uno dei
paesi che nel Mediterraneo che un mare
che si sta molto riscaldando è uno dei
paesi che sta messo a peggio perché
negli scenari peggiori appunto si
potrebbe rischiare di riscaldarci devi
addirittura 5 gradi in Italia che è
appunto uno dei paesi nel quali il
cambiamenti climatici sanno di parlando
sempre più gravi
dal da pochi Questa è un'immagine che è
stata presa proprio la settimana scorsa
a Ischia e uno appunto dei Paesi nei
quali i gli eventi estremi gli eventi
meteorologici estremi si ripetono con
Maggiore frequenza Voi vedete che dal
2010 ce n'erano pochi e guardate la
situazione oggi nel 2022 Dal 2010 al
2022 ci sono stati 1.500 3 anzi
1504 con Ischia eventi meteorologici
estremi con 279 vittime a cui dobbiamo
aggiungere le 12 vittime di Ischia
potrai continuare veramente molto a
lungo a raccontarvi i disastri dei
cambiamenti climatici che già oggi
vediamo tutti i giorni però io credo che
la molla per agire non sia soltanto il
disastro ma sia appunto il desiderio di
migliorare e oggi disponiamo
contrariamente a quando si cominciò a
parlare di cambiamenti climatici negli
anni 90 di tecnologie che migliorano la
nostra vita di una cultura che è più
sensibile a questo tema di appunto della
sobrietà e della solidarietà rispetto ai
cambiamenti climatici e tra l'altro cosa
molto importante anche se i cambiamenti
climatici non esistessero queste misure
queste tecnologie questo approccio ci
sarebbe molto utile perché perché
già oggi ci sono
450 mila morti premature in Europa
dovute all'inquinamento e il 15 di
novembre siamo diventati 8 miliardi di
persone quando Nel 1987 eravamo solo
cinque miliardi per di più nel mese di
luglio di quest'anno abbiamo superato il
numero di risorse necessarie per il
pianeta che il pianeta utilizza per
rigenerarsi ogni anno quindi stiamo
consumando troppo
Questo è un tema veramente molto
importante E cioè il collegamento fra il
cambiamento climatico che esiste e il
fatto che noi dobbiamo agire anche se i
cambiamenti climatici non esistessero ma
vediamo un po' quali sono le cose che
noi dovremmo fare non sono nuove
sicuramente ne avete già sentito parlare
un sacco di volte non è ripeto non è
nessuno scoop però la differenza oggi è
che noi le dobbiamo fare tutte insieme e
con la sensazione la stessa sentimento
di urgenza che tutti noi abbiamo
condiviso accettando delle misure
difficili durante il covip E durante la
pandemia covid e anche con quello stesso
ottimismo che tutti noi abbiamo tutti e
tutte noi abbiamo condiviso quando sono
arrivati i vaccini
Questo è il sentimento che noi dobbiamo
avere urgenza e desiderio e allora
vediamo qualcuna di queste cose che
dovremmo fare e anche alcune che non
dovremmo fare Beh io penso che la prima
cosa che non dobbiamo fare è pensare di
sostituire quando siamo adesso in una
situazione di crisi energetica la nostra
dipendenza dal gas russo con la
dipendenza del gas di qualcun altro e
per di più questa idea di svuotare le
casse pubbliche per aiuti a pioggia alle
bollette è un qualcosa che è
semplicemente non è sostenibile in
questo momento l'Italia è il paese in
relazione al PIL che sta dando più
denaro per pagare le bollette in un modo
relativamente indiscriminato in Italia
esistono due milioni e mezzo di famiglie
che non riescono a riscaldarsi o
identificarsi in modo decente e che
quindi vivono in case fatiscenti o
addirittura non hanno casa non è
pensabile di semplicemente pagando la
bolletta per queste persone di qua per
qualche mese di risolvere il problema e
quindi cosa dobbiamo fare Dobbiamo
investire molto di più nella
ristrutturazione delle case nel
miglioramento del nostro patrimonio
edilizio e ci sono le tecnologie per
farlo peraltro e anche questo è un
numero che ho appena appreso se tutte le
lampade tutte le illuminazioni interna
ed esterna fosse a led oggi noi
all'inizio della guerra avremmo avuto la
metà del fabbisogno di gas Russo Quindi
come vedete Esistono le soluzioni Oggi
possiamo ridurre di 10 volte il nostro
consumo energetico nelle nostre case e
lo dobbiamo assolutamente fare un'altra
cosa di cui avete sicuramente sentito
parlare sono le energie improbabili
eolico solare geotermico ce ne sono
abbastanza ce ne sono già tante e già
oggi sono molto meno dispendiose del di
qualsiasi addirittura anche del carbone
oltre naturalmente al gas al petrolio
Per non parlare del nucleare Ebbene oggi
noi abbiamo assolutamente il dovere di
insistere che efficienza energetica ed è
rinnovabile quindi nuove energie sono la
strada maestra non solo per liberarci
della nostra dipendenza ma anche per
cambiare il nostro modo di riscaldarci e
e di abitare un'altra cosa che dobbiamo
fare assolutamente addirittura a
spingere davvero i nostri governanti a
fare e quello di spendere bene i soldi
pubblici Oggi esistono qualcosa come 34
miliardi di euro nel bilancio dello
Stato che sono devoluti a sussidi
ambientalmente danno dannosi non lo dico
io è tutto sul sito del Ministero
dell'Ambiente quindi noi in un modo
cosciente spendiamo circa 34 miliardi di
euro all'anno per danneggiare l'ambiente
e questo evidentemente non ha nessun
senso se dobbiamo ridurre le nostre
missioni e adattarci al cambiamento
climatico E allora che cosa dobbiamo
fare Dobbiamo spostare queste risorse e
metterle in qualcosa che vale la pena
che vale la pena che ci aiuti ad andare
nella buona direzione l'anno prossimo
L'Unione Europea ha dichiarato l'anno
europeo delle competenze Ecco un po' di
questi soldi potrebbero andare a formare
nuovi lavoratrici nuovi lavoratori nuove
ricercatori nuove ricercatrici per
andare veramente nella direzione di
aiutarci a risolvere questo problema
la stessa cosa funziona per gli ospedali
insomma per fare delle cose utili altra
cosa che noi non dobbiamo fare è
sprecare soldi in opere pubbliche
inutili in questo momento nella nostra
regione Ci sono ancora un sacco di
ambizioni di tunnel autostrade per non
parlare del ponte di Messina o del
tunnel della Valsusa queste Oggi sono
opere che non sono prioritarie per
rimettere a nuovo il nostro territorio
ed evitare quello che è successo a
Ischia noi avremmo bisogno di 26
miliardi di euro 26 34 ci sta Quindi voi
Vedete che la discussione su come si
utilizzano le risorse pubbliche è
assolutamente fondamentale per
descrivere il nostro futuro e per
descrivere un futuro che sia possibile
una volta che abbiamo fatto tutto questo
abbiamo risolto i nostri problemi
assolutamente no perché la transizione
ecologica Non è una questione di tecnica
è una questione di costruire un nuovo
mondo e la costruzione di un nuovo mondo
non è soltanto una questione di esperti
è una cosa che devi coinvolgere tutti
noi assolutamente tutti
e tutte Evidentemente per esempio Dove
metto la pala eolica l'ho messa nel
posto giusto è meglio fare qualcos'altro
magari mettere fare più efficienza
energetica in quel luogo perché il
paesaggio è troppo bello devo mangiare
meno carne devo oppure devo diventare
completamente vegano devo viaggiare non
devo più viaggiare Oppure posso trovare
dei modi diversi e interessanti per
viaggiare senza avere un eccessivo
impatto devo riscaldarmi devo mettermi
tanti maglioni in attesa che il prezzo
del gas scenda oppure devo veramente
impegnarmi per cambiare e cambiare
completamente la mia casa chiedendo un
sostegno per farlo tutte queste sono
scelte sono scelte che hanno bisogno di
uno spazio Democratico per essere
discusse e adottate perché non tutte le
soluzioni sono adatte in tutte le
situazioni
Allora noi dobbiamo andare verso una
nuova forma di democrazia o per essere
più preciso non proprio nuova dobbiamo
Arricchire le forme democratiche che
sono soprattutto delle forme di
rappresentanza attraverso il voto no che
noi facciamo una volta ogni tanto a
tutti a tutti i livelli ma noi dobbiamo
aiutare le istituzioni e coloro che ci
rappresentano a interpretare meglio e a
capire meglio Quali sono le cose da fare
e devo dire la verità che questo tema
dell'arricchimento della democrazia è
assolutamente importante oggi nel
momento in cui noi vediamo a tanti
giovani donne e bambini anche morire
sotto i colpi della polizia di una
polizia iniqua e criminale in tanti
paesi del mondo dall'iran alla Cina alla
Russia all'afghanistan noi dobbiamo a
queste persone e al desiderio di
democrazia che queste persone hanno e di
libertà di fare in modo che la nostra
funzioni meglio e devo dire ci sono
degli esempi super interessanti
ultimamente in Irlanda per esempio non
tanto tempo fa la una grande riforma
istituzionale è stata fatta attraverso
un comitato di persone estratte a sorte
che hanno lavorato con degli esperti
Giuristi è stata una cosa super
veramente molto interessante in Germania
una grande mobilitazione di cittadini e
cittadine ha portato
il corso a un tribunale e questo
tribunale ha detto al governo tedesco
che doveva assolutamente cambiare e
migliorare la legge sul clima in Italia
esistono 35 35 comuni che decidono il
loro bilancio attraverso quello che si
chiama appunto il bilancio partecipativo
cioè co Decidono insieme al sindaco e
alla Giunta e al consiglio comunale come
spendere i soldi non l'anno scorso due
anni fa adesso non mi ricordo
Voi ricorderete che c'è stato tutto un
grande lavoro per le firme digitali
intorno al referendum sulla cannabis
tutti questi sono esempi di
partecipazione estremamente importante
che noi dobbiamo portare avanti
nel 2018 una ragazza di cui forse voi
avete sentito parlare che si chiamava
svedese che si chiamava che si chiamava
Greta thunberg è riuscita dopo un'estate
torrida e una grande campagna di stampa
e alcuni rapporti delle Nazioni Unite
veramente terrificanti a smuovere le
coscienze e a favorire una mobilitazione
di scuola e studenti giovani e non
giovani che hanno portato io credo al
risultato importante almeno a livello
europeo di cominciare quello che si
chiama il Green Deal cioè una lista di
azioni che porteranno l'Europa primo
continente al mondo a diventare
ammissioni Zero nel 2050 con il covit
questa mobilitazione sia un po' ridotta
se un po' afflosciata E noi allora la
dobbiamo riportare la dobbiamo
rinvigorire ma non soltanto andando
nelle piazze ma mettendo insieme quella
parte di politica di istituzioni di
attori economici di attori sociali che
credono fermamente che l'urgenza si deve
coniugare al Desiderio voi pensate quale
grande sfida intellettuale culturale
politica sociale questo rappresenta e
quale sforzo di creatività collettiva a
questo impone e anche quale Rinascimento
può disegnare e quale grande Liberazione
può significare Io penso che mettendo
veramente insieme desiderio di urgenza
ce la faremo
[Applauso]